[Music]
in celebrity catfight news oh yeah give
it to you submitted by one com oh is it
Nicki Minaj versus cardi B it is already
B and Nicki Minaj got into an
altercation at a New York Fashion Week
party do we have videos what kind of
altercation because I've been seeing
this online [ __ ] no like physical okay I
want to see a fight verbal like tweeting
back tweeting in cardia was like yeah
like these fools are all studio
gangsters like I want to hit don't want
to do this straight up but then no one's
down to do it and I'm like I believe
party like she's just a regular person
and she was a stripper and you know
strippers don't [ __ ] around super - oh
no I didn't know I don't know why she
hide that from us huh well I mean that's
according to a list of some celebs that
used to strip they didn't know so I
don't know how true that oh yes Ricky
was constructed her persona was
constructed it she's definitely as like
a studio made you know artist supposedly
I thought yeah I thought Nikki uh went
to like a performing arts school which
is why she's like extremely musical a
very good like for different
personalities that rapper yeah so talk
for me to be is just a straight stripper
that got picked up and like she had
natural talent probably if it wasn't on
JK news she could have stripped for it
for a brief moment in time maybe she
don't know like a charity thing yeah I
mean people think that jenna Marbles
shiftin she was a go-go dancer
oh the other one is that she's in a
porno
oh no she's not doesn't look I know I'm
just saying geo stop spreading rumors
about me stop murmuring about Jenna
Marbles she's good person with my career
long why don't you introduce us she came
to our wedding
yeah I wasn't invited oh yeah see I
google this Nicki Minaj revealed her
stripper name I never did not get Minaj
during her stripper day she already has
a stripper name she does ex-stripper
Nicki Minaj see I wasn't alright no
nobody was denying you two denied me Oh
cuz I was like why are you having this
argument no one was good night myself
and I needed to know if you can't say
that she did not say what her super
dudes argue with the comments that are
already coming after her okay so what it
was I know I do that I'm not disputing
the stripper part but then I know she
was like her post persona is constructed
it's a very carefully crafted persona to
say it by the Illuminati yeah none one
none Sally none salad man Sally none
salmon Oh
none none sandwich and Oh Andy space
salmon this says use your stripper name
is the corresponding choose a stripper
either no but this one dance is that
like look look where's your stripper
name the last thing you ate what in the
guy no no the color of underwear you're
wearing in the last thing you come
ex-stripper Nicki Minaj goes oh I'm
peach I'm blue peach that's let's see I
don't believe it I don't buy it I don't
think she's a real stripper stripper but
okay but I want to talk about the fight
I'm blue peach that's my stripper name
let it go now that works for you blue
peach yeah cuz peach is kind of a
stripper name yeah I'm red Mexican food
red taco I had a bunch though it's a red
Mexican food okay red guacamole yeah
alright talk about the fight so this
happened during New York Fashion Week
and this happened at harper's bazaar
icons party and i'm gonna show you the
clip it's really dark
oh yeah it's really dark so were they
fighting in those wacky outfits no Bobby
time you're like big-ass cow
looking swingin s starting [ __ ] people
are saying that this happened because
Nicki Minaj stepped on cardi B strain
and then like get to her dress and then
cardi B went off because she says that
Nicki Minaj is talking [ __ ] about her
being a mountain or the fact that like
did they already have beef it was it was
it was starting to boil yeah okay yeah
thank you
[Music]
could've been Nikki [ __ ] come here
[ __ ] you crazy [ __ ] come here [ __ ]
you crazy was Nikki the sounds like it
was carne part of you it sounded Nikki
was being the little [ __ ] and going
like you're so crazy while you're doing
this out here and that started me sounds
like come here imma give you some that's
a sound-alike
oh man who's your money on cardi BRE
wins every time
sorry I think she's bigger too no I
don't know I don't know the way menage
has been making herself the constructing
herself Minaj looks way bigger
oh and inside yeah she's been I thought
she was short I don't know maybe I'm
thinking maybe I'm mixing her with
[ __ ] like like Little Cayman yeah
Nicki Minaj look like she weighs like
180 she got that food she does big-ass
legs tits big ass little waist those
short but she looks like she's like very
very wide she carries it well yes that's
true she has a anacondas so cardi she
got apparently someone from Nicki like
one of securities cards from Nicki's
crew elbowed party right in the face and
you can see cardi leaving the party that
she put they but the biggest Chinglish
that's called a bruise swollen Bobby
shiner was a bruise it's like a cartoon
[ __ ] bum bum she probably put makeup
on she also took off her shoes during
the whole altercation and threw it out
here and then so she left barefoot
picked our [ __ ] shoes up Wow shoes
too dude her makeups looks flawless it
does yeah and then this is what she
posted on Instagram the sheets oh do you
want to read it
five little Ashly [ __ ] slide I let you
sneak this me I let you lie on me I let
you attempt to stop my bags [ __ ] up the
way I eat you've threatened other
artists in the industry told them if
they work with me you'll stop [ __ ]
with that I let you talk big [ __ ] about
me I addressed you once in person I
addressed you a second time in person
and every time you copped a plea but
when you mention my child you choose to
like comments about me as a mother
make comments about my abilities to take
care of my daughter is when all bets are
[ __ ] off I've worked too hard and
come too far to let anybody follow my
success but just talk all that [ __ ] and
they rest but in real life they [ __ ]
this shiz really is for entertainment
yeah I read that first so I thought that
that came out first before the fight
that's a good that makes sense why yeah
yeah yeah that's a good district yeah
yeah not like Eminem you're rich
yeah good distractive Jesus we all know
he's rich dude are you thinking what do
you mean Eminem versus mg okay yeah I
mean Eminem's gonna murder him
so there's that that's a given what did
I think about the M Jake I'm G K times u
K track I mean I thought the beat was
cool other than that I thought the
disses were weak they're pretty weak
everyone's like he bodied and like where
he'd be like yeah we're like he's like
oh he had a whole branch you're rich and
you it's old and I want to be big now
and like we'll get out of the game and I
idolized you and all the stuff oh and it
took you seven years to dis me back but
it's like yeah because he's [ __ ] busy
like you're nothing like what the [ __ ]
you're lucky you are made it into the
Midwesterners dude it's like it's like
oh hey who you guys think is gonna win
King Kong or an Italian mobster yeah
these how much they write yeah pay to
see this fight cardi B versus Nicki
Minaj I would pay just to see cardi B
fight anybody I want to see some like
hip-hop back again you know like I want
them you some solid diss tracks I want
them not rule yeah you remember when
eminent ended his career do you it was a
key it was 50 they talked about that you
guys probably don't even bring that up
did you know Eminem or destroyed his
career through what there is rap you got
to listen to this [ __ ] song oh my go
you mean that this track yeah no no
that's not what destroyed his career
though it was 50 cent that actually
destroys the other M&M found 40 cents
yeah and it was all that yeah yeah yeah
it was all the beef though but 50 cent
told Charu he'll kill him he didn't end
his career through a track he's like
you're a [ __ ] fake gangster I will
kill you at the scene tienda days like
that's some real [ __ ] yeah and that's
what I like to see yeah cuz you know
that I would say ja rule you don't rule
video but also when Joe was talking
about the diss tracks like the [ __ ]
districts against all he did work I mean
Joel was the easy target - yeah that's
true I mean Hughes just likes to do
gangster my jaw ruler 10 inches of suck
yeah Oh piggy into pot those were those
were those were the days word went
beyond hippie streets and guns and
violence Snoopy had rate like that she
was funky I like that that they do it
safely like not like they were
bulletproof vest you know I still like
the shooting a lot of people in that era
like a lot of a lot of like MCS in that
era hated that because hip hop wasn't
mentally as not meant to be that that's
true and in win the West Coast and the
Gators got together and then like they
made it so like real dog down I can see
that the point of hip hop was for people
in the streets to use an alternative way
of battling it's too bad that didn't
battle with squirt guns because that
would have been great and what if they
thought that squirt guns was like the
sickest [ __ ] ever
and so like they're all like drive-by in
with squirt guns and I just were cutting
each other everywhere like that
that'd be the same thing if like
breakdancers started actually fighting
yeah cuz it was supposed to be like a
way to instead of piss fighting that's
true
take it out on the [ __ ] floor mat you
know yeah [ __ ] imma [ __ ] it was so
[ __ ] funny and created though that
like the distance I was just like this
is [ __ ] dope imagine a big he didn't
get shot down and instead everyone's
like they're all they're all like hey
biggie remember when you're walking out
the club now you're all wet
see that would be nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]